[Music]
[Applause]
Your customer is asking for a new car
key. It happens all the time. They lost
it, dropped it in the sewer, or just
want new ones for their spouse or
children.
Autel has your professional level key
programmer to support any car in any
situation. The combination of key
programming and vehicle diagnostics
coverage in one tool ensures that you
will be able to complete the project the
first time. In this video, we're going
to unbox the IM 608 Pro and take a look
at the included parts. If you're
familiar with all the parts and just
want a demonstration of use in different
situations, Autel has a library of
vehicle specific how-to videos for your
reference anytime. And they include key
learning with the OBD and the XP400 Pro
unit. So, let's open the case and see
what's included.
The IM 608 comes with cables for the VCI
and XP400 Pro to use with the tablet
here, which is light and durable for
shop use.
So, let's power it on and see what the
features are like. Also, make sure you
register your tool to your free Autel ID
account and update the tool software.
You'll see IMO on the left, which
includes all the steps we recommend you
take. If you just want to do key
programming or diagnostics, you can do
that pretty quickly from this home
screen. The great advantage of the Autel
IM 608 Pro is the combination of key
programming, advanced diagnostics, and
maintenance service in one tool. So, you
can easily select different options from
these screens.
On the second screen, you can have help
from the Autel tech support team or
another professional remotely log in and
help you out if you're having trouble.
Data manager here helps you store and
view all your data. Shop manager for
vehicle history and workshop
information.
VCI manager to help you connect to the
VCI.
Function viewer to look up functions.
Digital inspection if you want to
connect a camera. And finally,
microscope to use your oscilloscope.
[Music]
This is the J2534,
which is the VCI or vehicle
communication interface that you will
use to wirelessly connect the tablet
with your vehicle's OBD port. For some
car models, you can use the VCI directly
to learn new keys. A lot of newer models
also need the included key programmer.
[Music]
So, this is the XP400 Pro key
programmer. And essentially, the only
difference between an IM 608 Pro models
is that this programmer has more ports
for advanced use, depending on what
vehicles and functions you want to
complete. The XP400 Pro can program even
more EROM and MCU chip types than the
XP400. Purchase the key programming
adapter kit, the IMKPA, to expand the
XP400 Pros capability and program BMW
EWS3 keys and Mercedes-Benz any NEC
keys.
Now, you may be wondering, when should I
use the programmer and when should I
only use the VCI?
The answer is it depends. It all depends
on the vehicle making model. Great
benefit is you don't need to worry about
making that decision. The IM 608
software will correctly identify the
vehicle model and during the key
programming procedure selection, the
software will confirm exactly which
units to use to complete the procedure
and provide step-by-step instructions of
how to complete it. If you have any
questions during this process, you can
contact the OTEL tech support team to
ask questions. We are always happy to
help support you and your team. If
you're using the XP400 Pro key
programmer, you need to connect this
cable with the tablet. If you're using
the VCI to connect to the vehicle, you
need to use this OBD2 cable. In
addition, remember, never connect the
J2534 unit to the XP 400 Pro key
programmer using the OBD2 cable. Please
read all setup instructions and follow
these and all tablet displayed
programming instructions carefully. Your
tablet should wirelessly connect by
Bluetooth to the VCI, but if for
whatever reason there's an issue, you
can use this USB cable to connect the
tablet with the VCI. Finally, we have
several chips included in the case.
These are for the advanced programming
situations and require professionally
trained locksmith use. The Autel
software reads the vehicle data from
multiple modules to confirm the system
encoding matches and displays it all on
the tablet. So after collision repairs,
if the system modules have been replaced
without proper coding or programming
into the vehicle system, the vehicle
security will not allow the key
programming to proceed. Technicians
first need to complete the necessary
repairs to allow the vehicle system
security access. This is why Autel
recommends only skilled professionals
operate the IM 608 to complete repairs.
But this is again what makes the IM 608
such an amazing tool to provide both key
programming and advanced diagnostics in
one. So all levels of vehicle repair can
be completed from one tablet. Let's tap
IMO which will take you through the
whole process.
Make sure you're connected to an
internet source for this.
You can auto scan your VIN to get the
car's info as that will make the setup
easy.
If you can't get the VIN automatically,
find the car model and tap it.
[Music]
You'll see automatic selection and
manual selection. Automatic selection
will take you step by step through the
process. You can use diagnostics and key
programming straight from the home
screen. Now, function viewer will tell
you exactly what your car's model can
do.
Tap it, then select your tablet in the
top left.
Your tablet is the IM 608.
If you're using the IM508 and select
508,
then select the car's make, model, and
year.
[Music]
After it loads, you'll see a lot of
symbols.
You can see what these symbols mean by
tapping the question mark in the top
right corner.
So, here BMW 8 series, we got some
square boxes.
It means you can make new keys using the
onbench method or in other words, using
the XP 400 Pro. My name is Mike and I
hope this video helped answer your IM
608 question. If you would like to see
more detail about the IM 608, you can
check out.com
or visit the Autel YouTube page to see
more from the Autel Training Academy
video library.